[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it dear grace and
Hank this is the weekly podcast where I
Hank green and usually John Green but
this week the amazing grace Helbig
answer your questions give you dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon but
first grace you have a poem for us yes I
do here we go ready it's an original
Levon sells cartoon balloons in town his
family business thrives Jesus blows up
balloons all day sits on the porch swing
watching them fly and Jesus he wants to
go to Venus leaving Levon far behind
take a balloon and go sailing while
Levon Levon slowly dies so it's there's
a lot of symbolism it's um I wrote this
in like third grade
this is actually yeah this is an excerpt
from my diary I had a crush on this kid
named Levon and I really he didn't like
me back so I wished that he would die
and there's something about balloons you
like - balloons then - yeah I was at a
kid's birthday party it was it got
complicated
Levon just didn't want any of this it
would be it would actually how wonderful
would it have been if you could have
actually found I shouldn't have people
do that bring on your childhood poetry
oh my god you have a nearby no I have
this yeah you can't see it in this audio
podcast but it's a Papoose hanging on my
wall that I made in fourth grade and we
were studying Native Americans and
social studies well I take that back my
dad made it on my behalf for a project
in fourth grade in which my teacher
instantly knew that I didn't make it
yeah no I would not have said that that
was something a fourth grader did no not
at all but it has lasted till now I'm 29
years old and I think I was eight and
you hadn't Justin you've got that just
in case yeah the baby shows up yeah
that's my baby bjorn it's just the pilot
sticks on the wall with some burlap
stress to it and a week in the yellowed
piece of paper with typewritten text on
it
yeah I'm sure says something very
sentimental
and there's so many spelling mistakes in
that thing but it was at the time where
you wrote everything on typewriters so
you didn't want to go back like this
days this is just how it tried to
spelled without in the e on the end trim
trim it was a great trip everybody if
you don't know who grace Helbig is
that's of surprise but she she has her
own podcast here on on whatever platform
you're using you're using you to listen
to this podcast it's called not too deep
with grace Helbig it's a lot like this
podcast except nothing at all like it
because because we talk about
existential crises and death and and
dealing with grief and and leaving your
friends behind you specifically have
titled your podcast in a way that if
anything like that happens you can quote
the title of the podcast and turn it
right around I mentally eject myself
from those situations yeah this podcast
is essentially everything that gets
repressed on my podcast I started my
podcast as a based off of Rhett and
Link's podcast because ear biscuits
their podcast is so deep yeah they're
like so tell me about your family yeah
they say darkroom they make you feel too
comfortable and then they ask you all
your secrets and insecurities and you
just tell them because they you trust
them and they're not such a soothing
voice and they play good-cop bad-cop but
even they're bad cop it's still kind of
a good cop and so you just trust and so
I left that podcast feeling very
vulnerable and so I wanted to make a
space on the podcast area that made
people not feel vulnerable that was just
full of dumb yeah my favorite thing I
like dumb - thanks it's one of my
favorite ways to describe something in a
complimentary way if I say like that's
so dumb I'm like that it's really great
yeah turn it around
mm-hmm it's like how hot cool Pat's
oh yeah Wow what how being hot is cool
no like the word hot and the word cool
mean the same thing
dope aging ourselves inaudible way
that's on on fleek yeah
am I in fleek right now make a video
about on fleek I'm fascinated by on
fleek anyway get it it's just another I
have a whole series of thoughts about
not just on fleek but every word that
makes cool of which there are in every
generation dozens yeah
and they last for such a small amount of
time but they also sort of stick around
a lot like hip and groovy yeah I try and
use tuna saying as it means to say cool
oh that's tuna because there used to be
a mic still be on this reality show
called wicked tuna
there's about these Boston tuna
fishermen and it's called wicked tuna
and so I used to say things that are
cooler wicked tuna tuna it hasn't caught
on the way like fleek has to get
diviners to get down on your tuna trip I
know goddamn that's where all the trends
start now and Vine isn't it yep yep yep
yep yep yep yep yep I'm good to know
my favorite is sort of like 20s slang it
was particularly when a show went really
well the reviewer would say or like that
press would say that it was boffo BOF fo
fo-fo I've never heard that before
yeah and it sort of for a little while
became czar like to mean awesome in
general but only for a tiny bit and and
having watched a bunch of old movies
occasionally I will hear or see the word
befo and I'll be like this word where
did it go bring it back it sounds like a
child with the speech impediment trying
to say Bravo might might be where it
comes from I wish that there's just this
Italian little boy that started this
trouble
it sounds just like it yeah words I
never know people are living it for
everything now I live for that yeah
people live for that or they die
I don't understand hot and cool yeah I
know it's just extremes we're just all
extremists I guess either we live for it
or we die yep yeah that makes sense yeah
it's very Shakespearean of these days
very Shakespearean all right do you want
to answer a question yes Kendall asks
dear Grayson Hank if you were to create
a hybrid of two animals what would the
two animals be and what would you call
your new species smiley face emoticon
whoo it's a hybrid of two animals what
about like a scorpion no already vetoed
a pelican they're like a pelican front
and a scorpion back but like score
Pelican Pelican so basically were just
shipping animals right now no well I
guess because you do have to get them
together to make the tie bird thing to
mate and so yeah we are shipping animals
would you want though a pelican size
like scorpion pale isn't that where the
poison is yeah no I wouldn't
I don't digits if you were to create
that doesn't mean that I want to have
one in my life oh yeah what would I what
would i okay
I think I'd want like an elephant seal
which you know mabry and I say that's
kind of our spirit animal every now and
then an elephant seal probably mixed
with like I want to say like
an eagle elephants eagle an elephant
seagull now that's a seagull man darn it
that's just a mix of an elephant an
elephant seal is essentially an elephant
and a seal already come together
sure I'm trying to make a hybrid of what
is already a hybrid I had to make
something pure okay oh no an elephant
seal is pure I can't you can't just
because we we thought that they look
like no stupid and all of you elephant
seals that download this podcast a
weekly basis I don't I don't mean to
polarize you um okay let me think of
something that's like more more of a
pure this is where I'm like what are
animals
Oh hmm okay
see I keep choosing like I wanted to say
a sea otter but then I'm like that's
already a hybrid that's a seal on a dog
got together and they to see my favorite
animal yes so you don't you want you
want a sealing a dog to get together and
make an animal just it just happens that
that's already huh yeah I think maybe
this is just leading me to believe it
all like I just want to see otter in my
life
at some point okay what about a ladybug
and a giraffe so would be like the teeny
tiniest little giraffe of all time with
like a like a carapace and it can fly
yeah that sounds great
a lady brass a lady breath rolls off the
tongue a lady rat yeah yeah sounds great
I'm into it or a gerbil
jim-jim bug bug I was thinking a gerbil
when you said your bug I was like a bug
gerbil a bug yeah and then I started
thinking what could you put a gerbil
with and make it more interesting it's
basically like what animal could you add
to an animal to make it and more
interesting or more useful animal yeah
this could go on for hours
can we just make an animal into
something that would be a very nice
mattress we got to get enough animals
combined so it'll be like a nice warm
living mattress that just wouldn't bug
me and I could sleep on it because I'm
very tired right now I sell
no you want a living mattress I don't
think I mean that's a waterbed no I mean
there might be like things living in the
water bed but hopefully I've been on a
waterbed but if not certainly ever slept
on one regularly no I don't think I've
ever slept on I've like laid on one but
I only have everything I think I slept
on one at like a sleepover once yeah
that was like childhood dream when I
first found out that a waterbed existed
I was like ah and then I heard some
crazy like possibly made-up story and
that like someone drown in their water
like no longer want or need pretty sure
that was made up I know but you never
know Jersey kids so you had to do
something to occupy our time okay we got
a question yeah this is from Aaron who
asks dear Hank and grace I've recently
moved to a small town for a job where it
seems like I don't have much in common
of the locals I'm a huge nerd and so far
everyone I've met seems to only enjoy
sports I've been invited to many more
basketball games than board games in
addition I suffer pretty bad with social
anxiety and I am an introvert and so I
can't seem to muster up the courage or
motivation to do something I just won't
enjoy how can I meet like-minded people
with similar interests there's a thing
called the Internet I think that might
be a helpful solution just never leave
the house yeah I think one you this
isn't bad like this is not a bad problem
and I've only recently resigned this in
my brain for myself over the past couple
years that I used to think being an
introvert was a bad thing and it's it's
not it just means that you gather your
energy when you're alone rather than
socializing with other people when you
socialize it depletes your energy and
there are people that are extroverts
that gain their energy from being around
other people and so I think
acknowledging that you're an introvert
is great because then you you have like
now data yeah on yourself and you can
figure out how to manage yourself in
situations and knowing that you don't
enjoy sports matches are great this is I
think this is really good deductive
reasoning to get to the thing that you
really want to do that you will enjoy
it's like when I look to order food and
I don't know what I want I start
thinking what do I not want and then I
mark all those things off until I end up
with
it's always sushi just always want sushi
all the time that's yeah you know you
mark off pizza before you get to sushi
very candid cheese might can do the
cheese you know one time I used to taste
a dumpster dive and really in college is
to eat a lot of food out of dumpsters
and I am it's like a personal choice or
like it's a money-saving thing looks
like a money saving thing okay but also
a personal choice okay and like I could
have made made it work with by me buying
food well yeah ramen is very cheap chef
one time I I was in is that the pizza
duster
okay it was Pizza Hut and I found often
times there would be like whole pizzas
oh yeah but I found just a huge like 10
pound ball of of like melted and then re
congealed cheese like they had put the
bag of cheese too close to the oven and
it all melted and then I couldn't
sprinkle it on the pizza and it was like
it was like difficult to lift I did take
it you know so maybe that's a sport that
you could get into the dumpster diving
for recently congealed cheese ah but I
would say that I have also found that
doing things sometimes I surprised
myself that I enjoy them I'm like you
know you sort of get to see you like
what is it about this thing that people
enjoy right and I and and there are lots
of different like I go to baseball games
in my little town is where there's you
know it's like the farm team for the
farm team it's they're not very good at
the sport they're much better than me
and they're all teenagers and I and like
you know you go and there's hot dogs
right and there's you know it's like
share yeah you're outside and there's
people yeah and mostly it's it's a
social experience like like and it's
sort of more social than going to a
movie or something because there's a lot
of sort of downtime
oh yeah too much has happened especially
in baseball like what is what is this
well this keeps throwing it and nothing
happens I know I
I do enjoy baseball games but every time
I go to one I think why why why is it
this this is just it doesn't have that
much going no not at all not at all I
also think yeah when you if you try to
think about a situation from a different
point of view you like you said can
surprise yourself of what you might
enjoy about it even if you start to find
one small like if it's just a hot dog
I go to baseball games and I always
almost always think to myself well I'm
gonna get a hot dog yeah so that's not
that's not gonna be bad exactly and it's
always good to remember no matter what
situation whether you are going to a
board game night or you are going to a
soccer game is to stay positive and
open-minded this is something I have to
remind myself all the time because I
will I'm also very socially anxious and
an introvert so when I go out I already
have like my radar up that I'm going to
have a moment that I don't enjoy and I
have to catch myself because that
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy right
so if I think about things positively
you can like people have said you can
choose happiness you can choose to be
optimistic about the way you experience
your life and it changes a lot of things
also if you talk to some of those people
that love sports you might find out that
they also love the nerdy things that you
are interested in it right well people
can have a lot of different things that
they like yeah totally turns out and if
there's a game store in your town I know
that this is terrifying the idea of this
is probably terrified it would certainly
be terrifying to me going to a game
store and being like hey so anybody play
games I could just introduce me to some
strangers and we can play some board
games together I would never do that but
it is a thing that exists it's the
possibility do do that I have friends
who do that like they move to a new town
and then like go to the games during
their like a any Magic the Gathering
tournaments and I'm like who does that
doctor total [ __ ] so but I would I will
say that because something is scary
doesn't necessarily mean that your body
is telling you not to do it right and
and I you know often times the scary
things end up being the most interesting
and the most fun and where I learned the
most about myself and about other people
yeah I live by the philosophy follow
your fear it's an improv philosophy um
because you know doing improv on stage
is inherent
very terrifying yeah because you have no
idea what's about to happen and so you
follow your fear because fear comes from
a place for you you're feeling this
thing about something because you care
about it if you didn't care about it
there would be no feeling about it
right but fear usually usually comes
from a place of care and so when you
follow it it's really interesting to see
where you find yourself sometimes it's
not where you want to be but sometimes
it is yeah take a chance you only live
once we're all gonna die someday yay
you're given the hang of it I'm getting
right away mortality is looming around
all of us should I read Isaac's question
yeah please
okay Isaac asked dear grace and Hank I
want to study physics in college however
I am quite sure that I will not get into
Harvard or Yale or any really fancy
school do you think it's still possible
to make contribution to the scientific
community parenthesis this doesn't apply
just to physics and parenthesis without
going to an incredibly challenging /
expensive university question mark
Thanks yeah yes the answer to your
question is yes most physicists didn't
go to Harvard or Yale or any fancy
school yeah and most people that do
really interesting things in a variety
of fields didn't go to the greatest
school for the thing that they've done
something cool within yeah I mean like
it's it there are advantages to going to
fancy schools with big reputations and
like you know it's nice to be able to be
like a Harvard physicist and people will
be like yes you are legit and that is
clear to me from that from those two
words put together yeah but there are
lots of lots of schools where I mean I
went to I got my chemistry degree from a
tiny liberal arts school where there
were in my year for chemistry graduates
wow really yeah Jesus so I and I got a
great education I learned a lot I did
applied research I you know I'd like I
you know smaller schools you can get a
lot more attention and really until
graduate school that doesn't room
much if you're gonna be a physicist like
it you know it it can but like you know
establishing yourself like there's a lot
of different ways to do that in a lot of
different ways like in undergrad too and
yeah it is not about what school you go
to no not at all I when I got my
communications degree from a small
liberal arts college and when I first
went my first semester I was like so
bummed by the school and you know it had
no notoriety behind it that I started
filling out transfer applications to NYU
and to you know to Tisch and all these
schools in New York City that I thought
were more legitimate and by default
would make me a more legitimate
communications major and then I ended up
staying at my school because I got a
scholarship there and no that's a good
reason to stay and I realized that this
study and the individualized study that
I got because it was such a small school
was so much more meaningful in the
long-term of my career and world and
trajectory than me being one of a
billion kids at NYU trying to be a
communications major so yeah each NYU
just kidding also you can just buy the
sweatshirt and no one will know that you
didn't go to Harvard or yeah it's okay
they sell those shirts everywhere
Elizabeth asks dear Hank and grace I
just recently graduated from college and
I'm feeling highly anxious at the
realization that I'm never going to live
near all of my closest friends again and
at the prospect of making new friends
and acting like an adult so I've gotten
so comfortable with my friends that I
feel really uncomfortable around new
people do you have any advice for
dealing with the real world making of
new friends / starting your new life is
a quote unquote real person whoa well
just resign yourself to it's gonna be
terrible it's funny I like this question
has like a specific element which is
like I have to make new friends and a
nonspecific element of I'm terrified of
life yeah well that's you know story of
my life both of those things are real
issues well that's
I lived for so long and I wrote about
this in my book hey book plug Isaac for
so long believing that you could not
make friends as an adult I just could I
heard I thought that I thought that you
made your friends in like your formative
like adolescent years and those were the
friends that you just carried through
life and I didn't have a lot of friends
when I was in you know middle school in
high school in college and so I would
get really anxious and upset that I
wasn't gonna have friends for the rest
of my life and then I got involved in
activities like improv comedy and like
YouTube and started becoming parts of
communities and within those communities
finding like-minded people that had my
sense of humor and were interested in
the same things that I was interested in
and me you know making a point to be
open to having relationships with these
people led me to some of the best
friends that I have in my life right now
and so it's terrifying it's it means you
put yourself out there yeah I mean every
day you could make a best friend it's
like finding a relationship like finding
a romantic relationship you have to be
open for it to be in your life and yeah
it's funny because we have all this
infrastructure around finding romance
and like all of this cultural stuff and
baggage I'm a website procedure of
dating and and perhaps and in just all
these cultural institutions but we don't
really have that for friends no you just
you how to make friends no it's either
like it's this person who's next door to
me in my dorm or the person the people
who like were on my track team in high
school you know and like and and also
like I had it's one of the crazy
rewarding things for me about having
hired a bunch of young people to help
edit video and run run businesses for me
is that like I've just watched them all
become bud yeah and they're like go out
and do stuff and play board games and
I'm like I just like I like I did
oh my head and I get it'll be like seven
o'clock at night and I'll be leaving
work and I'm like why are there still
people here and I'll poke my head in
there there's like it in the studio like
they've got the board like the table set
up in this huge board game and I'm like
what are you nerds doing yeah it's um
it's it's yeah there's so many I think
I've learned this is so sad when I was
in college I I remember freshman year of
college I had such a bad adjustment to
college and I didn't make like any
friends and I was so like depressed and
sad and anxious and I remember going to
the like I guess just a general area
where there's all these bulletin boards
and clubs put up their flyers everything
because I remember the night before
laying in bed thinking to myself on a
very sincere level how do you make
friends like how would you break it down
how do you do give me the right words to
say exactly I'm like what is the process
and so my thinking and like trying to
analyze it led me to believe that I
should put myself in clubs where there
are people that could potentially be
friends and so I went the next day and
stood in front of the bulletin board and
looked at all these like clubs and I
thought to myself like which would be
make the most sense to me to join and I
joined one like volunteer like activism
ish type of club I don't remember what
it was and I showed up and there were
like three people there and they were
all just doing it so they could have
this club on their resume and I was like
well this totally failed and that I
would go back like to my drawing board
in my dorm room and be like now what do
I do
oh I guess I should get some hobbies and
a job a job you make friends that you
have fellow like co-workers I got a job
yeah it's use if don't like constantly
put yourself out there mm-hmm
yeah it's I'd say that you know most of
my friends I made in school like even
now as I went to grad school in the
place where I currently live and so so a
lot of my grad school friends still live
there and yeah god it's so hot like and
when I look at how those friendships
formed it had a lot to do with like one
or
to really like intentional people who
are like we're gonna become friends
we're gonna do activities and like
really like guilting people into doing
stuff because you're all like I just
wanna sit at home yeah and also being
like look I'll pay Oh like yeah it'll be
my car I'll get the gas like really like
lowering and like I'm so thankful to
those people right and and I'm like you
can't like intentionally find one of
those people but you could potentially
intentionally become one of those people
yes and like if you can find a group of
people who are like just like you or
they're like be like yeah look let's go
karaoke it's gonna be dumb right and
it's an activity we don't have to talk
to each other the whole time looking
like ease into this friendship yeah sit
around and just watch other people make
fools of themselves you don't even have
to do it exactly it is true because
they're being friends with someone is is
work friendships are work you I am one
of those I'm a bainham personality so
I'm not an alpha I don't take charge and
plan things and organize events and like
rally people together but I make really
good friends with alphas because of that
factor that I I need someone like that
to do that for me but there have been
times in my life where I've been like I
really like that person grace just asked
them to hang out with you like just
don't like oh god what if I asked them
and they say no it's like then they say
no you continue both living your lives
and you ask again at another point yeah
it's weird I I remember so once I had
once Catherine and I were pretty well we
weren't married yet but we were real
real close yeah we were um in that
trajectory I think it was clear by that
point we went out and like we met a
couple of new people who were friends of
friends yeah and like we went home and
we were like I really like that like
what's that like is that this seems like
I feel like I have a crush on the couple
yeah yeah and it's like but there's like
I'm looking at this I'm like what a
black nerdy 27 year old thing like
stable relationship thing to feel like
we can watch old movies with them we can
do activities together what do you think
like oh we have conversations like this
because we both have those feelings that
think about every other person that's
having the right feeling and someone
else that's waiting on the other end of
the line hoping that you will ask them
to hang out and you'll be surprised it's
like these all kind of have like a
running theme of like putting yourself
out there and following your fear into a
place that might be really beneficial
for yourself offer to cook them dinner
oh that's a good it's a really good one
because then they come over to your
place and like you're comfortable there
but like you're doing them a favor so
they feel like they kind of like it's
okay to like get out of their comfort
zone a little or make them cook you
dinner
okay like hey hey I think you're great
would you cook me dinner so that we can
become best friends or even if it's like
like a couple wanting to hang out with
another couple
I think activities like you know a taco
night or something where everyone can be
involved in doing something while having
conversation and like eating drinking
whatever being social it's it's always
helpful to just have an activity so that
people don't feel totally uncomfortable
with myself which is why board games
exist yes that's true this is why nerds
love board games so much and so that we
can hang out with people without
interacting okay I'm gonna go to Rosie
cuz I skipped her go to Rosie yeah okay
Rosie asks dear grace and Hank I am an
aspiring writer and filmmaker but it
seems as if everyone I meet was aspiring
to do those same things are more
talented and better situated to succeed
should I keep trucking on or do I
attempt to find a more sustainable
career path that might not be my
quote/unquote dream any advice how do
you motivate yourselves when you were
starting out whoo-hoo
Wolfie doofy wowie Zowie I yeah I feel
like all things that you could be doing
with your time are training for being a
writer and film maker if you want that
thing you can be doing anything
because writing is all about empathy
understanding people understanding
yourself and being able to like like put
down words that other people will enjoy
and that you will know that they will
enjoy it without having them look at it
first yeah and also um there's I I can
say that I have constant self-doubt that
I'm not good at what I'm doing and
everyone else around me is much more
suited for this so I should be doing
something else at the end of the day you
have to take like analyze what it is
that you're doing and does it make you
happy do you enjoy it does it
financially you know it does it can you
make money during it can you be yourself
yeah it can give a stable life with this
both emotionally and financially and you
but if it doesn't if you actually think
this is because there's been moments in
my life where I thought my dream job was
something and then when I analyzed it I
realized no I actually does not my dream
I've always said that that's my dream
but it's really not so this might be a
moment in which you analyze this and you
don't want to do at writing or
filmmaking or you do and if you do you
just keep going because I always say
when I get asked about making web videos
and like building your brand online that
it's consistency over time and you you
really have to be dedicated and for me
it's taken a long time to realize that
not having overnight success is the most
beneficial thing oh yeah because that's
such a stressful thing so hard I mean
like I always say kudos to jenna Marbles
for really truly being able to you know
build off of a viral video and create
and sustain a brand but it's so hard to
do that and it doesn't happen very
easily yeah and it can be really
emotionally awful like it is so such
like you don't know what is you don't
know what your goals are it's just this
thing that's happening to you and then
there are lots of people who are trying
to turn you into something yeah valuable
for them absolutely which was later than
really nice to have a nice slow
a pill yeah it makes you appreciate it
because you have you have moments of
minor success that make you appreciate
bigger successes in your life so much
more and I always think that it's it's
really it's good to not believe that you
are the absolute best at something
oh yeah does anybody think that well you
know that always makes when someone is
you know like I'm number one on this and
like has that kind of elitist mentality
I get so anxious for them because my
parents have really instilled a level of
humility in me as a human being and I
feel like if I ever begin to believe
that I'm the best at something I need to
stop doing that thing because I will
become a monster yeah and so thinking
that you're not the greatest is kind of
good to keep your own oh yeah I don't
know anyone who really feels that way I
think some people maybe project that in
order to like Mattox acute crushing it
yeah but I think you know at nobody
thinks that they are like I have always
like I was just at this you know YouTube
conference for educational content
creators and I'm instrument of like the
Jim Henson Company and the Sesame Street
and all you know like really old school
brands that make really amazing things
that I'm so enamored of and and like of
course like I kind of look at it I'm
like what am i what am I doing here
and why I may even try like I should be
working for one of these companies not
trying to do my own thing yeah like if
that's even possible and but at the same
time it's like I like the thing I do
mm-hm and maybe and like they seem to
think that I am good at it you think
Brad just showed up next to us like sang
over the rainbow so I yeah I think
everybody always feels like a little bit
of a faker I've always felt like a
little bit of a faker yeah cuz none of
us actually know what we're doing in
this whole universe everything but the
thing that is great about you know what
what Rosie is thinking about as a career
is that creating is really valuable
whether or not it's your career or not
mm-hm and I know a lot of people who are
able to and are
really rewarded by the things that they
make despite the fact that like you know
this isn't something that they make
money off of
no it's and I've always kept myself in
check in that am I doing this for only
financial reasons right now if I am I
can go wait tables and make money like
what am I doing this for am i doing it
because this is something I'm actually
passionate about and really enjoy and
proud of the content that I'm creating
in terms of her asking about motivating
yourself when you're starting out I I
think there's a couple different ways
that I motivate myself and one is when
I'm feeling not inspired not the best
feeling like a pozer feeling like I'm
not good at what I'm doing I submerge
myself in people that I think are doing
it really well I remember starting out
and watching kollene do mirandasings and
just feeling this like inspiration of
this is the funniest thing I want to do
stuff like this and like let that
inspire me and infuse into like the way
I make videos and every time that I
start to have one of those dips or like
I'm creatively tapped out right now I'll
just go and watch videos or movies or
read books about from people that I
think are really creative and are at the
level that I hope to be at someday I
also create in other areas like I'm
supposed to be writing my second book
right now and I am so hitting a wall
with it that I just went it and bought
some shirts and some transferable paper
and some paint pens the other day and I
made myself some t-shirts and I felt
really good after that because
creativity kind of lends itself to other
forms of creativity and so um it sounds
like you're a creative person and maybe
you will get Rhian spired by kind of
doing something else that's creative
that gives you a brain in a second away
from the writing in the filmmaking get
some beads make some bracelets see what
happens
here's a really awful thing about me oh
I so I've made a lot of stuff in my life
okay and sometimes when I'm feeling like
I suck mm-hmm and I'm not good at
anything mm-hmm I will go and watch old
me videos or old
like read old Hank essays and be like
that was funny yeah it's a funny guy
he's pretty so I feel like if you make
stuff you can like at least like I mean
and and of course sometimes I watch an
old Hank video and I'm like that was
awful what the heck was going on that
week but I I'm really you know like if
you the more stuff you make the more
stuff that you make that you actually
end up being proud of and if you can be
proud of something that you made it's a
lot harder to to get down on yourself
about it yeah I I'm I mean I'm awful - I
do that same thing yeah because there's
a handful of videos and a handful of
like live performances that I've done in
my life that I'm really really proud of
and think like good job old me yeah
really we're creative and I don't know
where that came from who the who is that
person that's being so like free and
clever and interesting yeah and so
that's it's also really motivated and
it's hard to and you can't cultivate
those things and you can't have that
have those special moments where you
like sort of exceed your expectations of
yourself unless you try a bunch like
it's gonna be 10% of the time that you
actually make something that you're like
you know years later you'll be like wow
I know am i that good
can I really and I can I write that well
and then when you've done with your
existential crisis about who you are
based on who you were find some sort of
inspiration there yeah it's never too
deep here on deer Hankin know we're all
gonna die someday
answer every question that's also how I
motivate myself a lot of the time it
sounds so insane but we were on Hannah
Hart and I were on set shooting Elektra
one diner girl and we had a couple of
days where we had to do some really
intense scenes with each other and we
would like Hannah was having trouble one
day doing this AK really intense fight
scene that we had to do with each other
and I literally right before the take
just whispered to her we're all gonna
die someday so why don't try something
interesting walked away after it she was
like dude that really helped I
like yes girl these people watching me
like we're all gonna be dead so I may as
well try and do something that I think
is really interesting and totally cool
and free out of my brain then you did
like a great philosopher Drake you only
live once yeah
Cassie asks dear Hank and grace what TV
show would you go back in time to be in
what do you have one no no not at all
you need time to think oh yeah man yeah
I my instinct like my initial response
is friends mmm you'd be so great on
friends I've done that make you sad just
thinking about it well one I'm a
practical reason because they got a
two-bedroom apartment in the Lower East
Side and they were both broke and how
that doesn't happen in New York at all
so they lived in some wonderful
beautiful fantasy place - I think that
Phoebe is one of the funniest female
characters on TV so underrated so funny
what I when I watched friends as a kid
yeah I hated Phoebe right and going back
she's the only character I actually like
that I would like want to hang out with
yeah the rest of them are kind of awful
yeah the rest of them are very yes super
yeah he's the only one who's naughty and
she's a bit of an artist she's but she's
completely self-aware about it was
bizarre floaty like hippy a referral
thing but she's um yeah I think she's
one of the funniest characters
especially as a female that you look
back on and they all were great like
that sideshow yeah that shows phantom
you can watch wheel I just recently
rewatched the whole thing and I was like
oh that's why this was so popular
exactly you don't watch any episode at
anytime without any context before after
of the storyline and laughs within 30
seconds yeah at someone it's I so that's
my initial would you want to be a main
character on friends you want to like
like just to show like a Gunther yeah
it's just like in the background it has
a couple like moments like it's so like
have craft services in between takes I
was my I would love to have been on a
Star Trek The Next Generation I just
like put me in Ferengi makeup and and
make me spout about capitalism I would
love that
that was Whoopi Goldberg on that yeah
yeah I watched I was she was like the
Gunther of Star Trek generation well
because she asked she basically asked
for a part on the show she told it to
Hannah one
interviewed her in New York she's like
it's LeVar Burton it's on there yeah
that he was saying you know or she was
they were having a conversation but
there wasn't enough african-americans in
the sci-fi genre and so he was like
mommy just ask oh so she liked all the
photo creators and was like give me a
part everybody want to be
she's like bartender sure why not
which I thought was so cool you're like
God you've just always been powerful
haven't you will be seriously and I
wasn't but when the question when you
first looked at me and said do you have
an answer for this my thought was Twin
Peaks uh see I've never seen twin oh my
god I'm sorry
out the window I need that window here's
my okay here's my substation with Twin
Peaks when I was in college the first
friends that I did make freshman year
were the Bulgarian transfer students
that lived on my floor there were all
computer science majors and they lived
there all year round because they didn't
go back home to Bulgaria and they were
obsessed with Twin Peaks sit in the
common lounge and watch it on TV all
together cuz none of them had TVs in
their dorm room and it was hilarious
they loved it so so much but yeah I knew
should watch them it's on Netflix now
yeah it's like one and a half it's it
the first season is a master like it is
one of the best things that ever
happened on TV it's amazing have they
tried to bring it back yeah there was an
effect that may be coming back but Lynch
you heard it here address had to back
out because of like some drama
so like the guy who created it isn't
working on the reboot right now which is
well that's about my disappoint you know
it's a show that I would love to be on
Mystery Science Theater 3000 oh wow that
would be fun can you imagine yeah you
and a bunch of robots yeah those guys
are like super active in the nerd
community I'm like I'm like very dads I
had don't I don't think I've ever hung
out with any of them but I'm hang out
with lots of people who hang out with
them so if you ever want to hang out
with them oh my god my brothers would
like their dad right there very funny
penis culture they went
live for that I yeah that was one of my
first like for yeas as a little girl
into comedy my older brother used to
watch Mystery Science Theater 3000 and
he would put it on and we'd all have to
watch it and I didn't understand it at
all but I'd laugh whenever he laughed
and then as I got older it was like oh
that was really funny that concept is
just such a ridiculously yeah there's a
there's a youtube show called welcome to
the basement which is like Mystery
Science Theater accepted except it's
sort of bookended by more serious
commentary about the movie how they
watch old movies and like then in the
middle they sort of like just take clips
from the movie like the funniest moment
that they're funniest moments not the
shows but it is it's it's like a
distilled Mystery Science Theater it's
so fun yeah I'll give you the link
please Jill yeah there was a question
that wait let me see how long we've been
going yeah we've been going for 1400
measures okay yeah I I there was a
question that I didn't put in that that
mostly I just want to ask you this
question it was such a good question but
it felt very sort of vain okay because
it sort of adjusts a question that I
want to talk with you about that I don't
necessarily think that other people
would necessarily care about but how do
you decide what opportunities to take
because lots of people come a-knockin
and yeah like I'm imagining there's a
number of nodes that come out of the
mouth of the hellbug um well I come from
you know the comedy world background
where YouTube wasn't going to be my job
I was auditioning for TV films so
there's you learn a sense of hustle that
you say yes to everything because you
have no idea which you know friends
pilot or which you know co-workers web
short is gonna be seen by who and then
lead to what so you and also the general
rule and improv is to say yes and and so
I've I've only recently learned about
saying no being okay I have for so long
been the person that says yes to
everything and then freaks out that I
can't do everything and then deals with
my internal anxiety of
to potentially let someone down by not
doing something and now I've learned
that it is much better for myself and
for that person if I just say no
outright then yes but so I now the way
that I measure I still have a lot of
that mentality of wanting to be able to
do everything and help everyone it
probably comes from just like a
deep-seated emotional place of just
wanting everyone to like me but yeah but
with opportunities I've also never had a
plan I've never had a five-year plan a
one-year plan I've been facing six our
plan yeah I live in like 15 minute
timeframe and I've been thinking about
getting a plan but I don't know if
that's just my style I don't know if it
works for me so I say yes to things
based on a lot of good reaction I think
about I really really really in have
since day one of making web videos put
myself in the audience's shoes is this
book I'm writing it's this movie we're
shooting is this video I'm making
something I would want to read or watch
or share and so if it is then that's a
no-brainer a lot of times I have to
really think about it and really try and
separate myself and are the people
involved in this good people when we
were making the television show um my
biggest kind of grounding philosophy on
hiring people was no dicks
I didn't I can't I'm very passive and I
just wanted to work in an environment
with people that said yes people that
liked what they were doing people that
were actually having a good time and so
that's kind of my gauge with yours yeah
it's a gut thing yeah me mostly it's
like since I live in Montana right it's
like I add a fault no age I think weeds
out a lot of people from even asking
good but I I have a lot going on that's
like in the studio I have to be doing
special and crash course all the time
right
and I have people relying on me to run
the business and to make the content so
that they can do their jobs and so that
is a huge limiting factor so I basically
don't say yes
less I think it's a good thing for the
world or if it's gonna make me make it's
gonna make me do something really cool
that I wouldn't have done otherwise
Oh or it's gonna make me feel really
good like it's gonna like if like I had
I had an asteroid mining company be like
do you want to promote our Kickstarter
with brent Spiner from Star Trek The
Next Generation and I was like yes I
want to do that I didn't want to do that
can you give me a certificate saying I
did that and and like at an Air and
Space Museum it was like anyway like
Lake livestream from under a giant
airplane it's amazing that's cool so I
yeah it's it's kind of like I'm a little
ashamed for it to be about like if
there's gonna be a really super cool
experience right no you're like going to
France with yeah Kathryn and like yeah
yeah I mean it that's when you know
mamrie Hart and I did this travel series
at the end of last summer called hey USA
and it was a series that just developed
out of a really organic idea that we
travel so much we should have a sloppy
Travel Show and just happened to
offhandedly mention that in a meeting
with a company about something else and
they love that idea and it just
developed in front of us and then we
both said yes to it because of the
experience now looking back on all the
things that we did in the time it was it
was really fun there's also really
stressful because it was so much travel
in a short period of time but in
hindsight the experiences we had would
never have happened to us otherwise yeah
and I was jealous watching that show you
guys looked like you had a lot we tried
so hard season 1 to get them to send us
to Montana so we were hanging out with
I remember yeah and then they were like
so we realized we can't do an entire
episode where you just hang at your
friend Hank's house always there's stuff
to do I could take you out for pizza boy
my question to you is there something
out there that you haven't been asked to
do yet that you really like hope is
there like Oh kind of yeah I like to
give talks oh cool I and but I only like
to give talks like I don't like to be
paid sure that makes sense thank of
course all of these ears perk up like he
likes to give talks without financial
gain yeah well we have Noah Torian for
you but I I like I'd never have time to
do it I've been asked to give
commencement speeches several times and
I've like always wanted to but never can
oh it's just never like it's I mean I
saw I watched yours yeah it was one that
was Anna came up that I was afraid of it
I was like no I should just do this this
sounds and I didn't get paid for it
when that was the thing online
everyone's like I'm pretty sure she got
paid for and that's like absolutely not
that was my college that I went to and
it just seemed like such a cool
honorable thing to do yeah yeah so I
always liked it so I sometimes like make
like I like get that bug out to like
make a video to the people who are
graduating I've done several times now
and and so I but I kind of would want to
like I give I've given a couple of sort
of TED style talks which I really enjoy
doing and and I also like there's a part
of me that wants to host a science
series and whether that's like mini Docs
or a TV thing but like I would I just
like the my fave some of my favorite
things in the world are like nerds
talking about science and being excited
about it which is what I do on the
internet a lot right but but doing that
in like a like a high budget situation
would be really cool but a huge amount
of work because I would not just I would
not let that be like you write all the
words down and then I say them right
have to be something that you'd want to
be really involved yeah yeah
that sounds really cool feels like that
could be something that happens in the
future yeah who knows who knows softer
things it's now in the universe so if
the secret really works it's gonna
happen my mom's told me lots are things
is that a phrase that I've just never
heard also things thoughts are things I
think that's in the secret a whole bunch
and you put it out there that it exists
and it grows into something in the
universe my mom tried to make me listen
to the secret on tape with her one time
and it's just so many Gong noises that I
checked out yeah that's not that's not I
don't think that's my bag all right that
was our last question grace oh my god my
dear that I can go back to my podcast
and talk about pants pooping stories oh
god I'm so sad that I'm not gonna be I'm
not too deep this time because I want to
tell you my pants pooping story next
time save it save got it already
oh I can't wait so I just time for the
news now though do you have any news
from AFC Wimbledon blah blah Dee Bloo
football blue P striker the dance every
moment and that's the UM the the thing
over in Europe football yeah it's
football team yeah yeah yeah yeah you
talked about it when he was on the
television show and he said they cuz I
asked like how was the team doing where
are they in the ranking and he said you
guys moved into another league something
like that and then I don't think what's
once upon a time they moved into another
league they didn't do that this year
yeah but they are they are not leaving
this league which is a weird thing about
English soccer which and ever like this
doesn't matter at all sure to you or
anyone okay
as far as but there are a bunch of
different leagues and unlike in American
sports where a player just sort of rises
the ranks the whole team can rise up the
ranks so if you're in like the top three
spots of league of league two then the
next year you're in league one and then
if you're
top two or three spots and that league
then you rise began oh and if you're a
but if you're in the bottom two or three
then you drop leagues right and that's a
huge deal because you lose a bunch of
money it was a bunch of sponsorships
here like you aren't in in the game FIFA
anymore oh my god David Beckham looks
down on you he does yeah he does that
anyways he's so tall yeah I I don't know
much about European football but I went
and saw my first like real real match
two years ago or a year ago and I loved
it the environment I mean talk about the
antithesis of a baseball game yeah so
much fun everyone knows these Cheers
and they know so many of them I think I
watched Carthage play I don't remember
the name it will come to me later but
they the fans were going nuts they're
standing the entire time how they all
knew it was probably like twenty or
thirty original chair entire match and
the kids are doing it it's like a lot of
dads and sons and it was it was really
really fun I wouldn't I want to see this
like a sociological study of the
evolution of a football chant somebody
has to come up with that but then it has
to spread around and so they're like you
you're like I want to see like the guys
at the bar who are like okay they like
the guys name that we want to make the
chant about his name is Jeremy Williams
yeah so what rhymes with Williams yeah
they're all on rhyme zone calm
it was like at the bar on their iPhones
runs oh yeah I would love that but
there's one guy it just goes home every
week and like test out new Cheers
that'll be so great all right so what is
the news the news from Mars is that it
looks like Mars might have been a lot
more icy than we previously believed
according to a new study that used
atmospheric models to study how water
would have moved between Mars is surface
and its atmosphere
lead investigator Robin Wordsworth ran a
number of models at different
temperatures and the model that most
closely modeled the eroded features of
Mars was the cold model where all the
surface was ice water
I see wha well the surface water was ice
and that that many of Mars's surface
features are better explained by ice
than by running water though there is
other evidence showing clear signs of
liquid water this is a sign that Mars
may have spent more time as a snowball
than as a water world Wow
they watched the movie frozen on Mars
and it got trendy maybe it was Elsa ah
that's what Elsa lives probably uh oh
that makes so much sense right because
there's that like weird snowman guy
which probably couldn't have happened on
earth he's probably actually at Mars you
know native species probably a native
species of Mars said now it all makes
sense
frozen is just a you know an educational
tool about the solar system we're
learning so much so that's it for this
episode of dear Hank and John a guest
hosted by grace Helbig John sorry John
you've been replaced grace is the
creator of youtube.com slash its Grace
and a wonderful podcast not too deep
available here wherever you're listening
to this also of Graces guide available
wherever books are sold
and also the grace Helbig show on on e
is that coming back um we can talk about
probably I can't talk about it it's in a
hiatus mode right now
so it's sleeping okay we'll see if it
wakes up which more people should have
watched yeah I should get off your damn
computer
talk about real lesson in the way the
media is going you guys listen to this
podcast I mean it's really hard to get
you guys to turn on a television I can't
be upset because I don't do it either
yeah and also a number of other amazing
things that you just are always doing
always doing things you have to go - hey
USA hey you say clapping with every
single youtuber good luck drumming Diana
Krall oh let's rope and diner girl yeah
a lot of really cool exciting things
many many things
our theme Bea's our theme music our
theme music is by gunnarolla the podcast
is edited by Nicholas Jenkins if you
have any questions for us you can send
them to Hank and John at gmail.com as we
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
that's not very powerful
[Music]